it is part of the part of the life of
here you cannot delete it so I just I
just wanted to give it in you new kind
of face I hope just make some questions
in people's mind that what's going on
around themselves
here in Kabul I try to use some their
shop colors it was first because I I
personally liked this kind of color
reason was because the environment
doesn't have that much color it's just
kind of monotone
I'm not saying it is political it's not
political because I don't want to make a
direction for that I just wanted to be
open I just wanted to get free from
housing because everything's here is
going to be seen from the lens of
politic
you